one by one by one by one that is very
scary it's not a duplicatable skill set
for a guy like him to do hey guys I'm
off the grid for August but my buddy
Patrick Bet David is making sense as he
usually does thank you for handling a
little of the nonsense pbd while I am
God when you talk about Tucker uh what
you were doing on the podcast space he
was doing on a mainstream space yeah
like very interesting now when you think
about Talent I'm sure if Fox invites you
and says Hey Joe we'd love to have you
on a guess for 10 minutes segment like
that I'm not doing a 10 minute segment
it's probably not going to be your style
to gonna want you know go on Newsmax or
fox or CNN to give a 10 five minute
answer that you give America doesn't
want that anymore right and a lot of
these guys that have these TV shows for
them to go from there to doing a podcast
they think it's easy it's not for
everybody you know you're used to
reading a teleprompter hey so earlier
today at 6 PM you know Devin Archer did
this right but Tucker
it's comfortable there right you know
when he did the Iowa Event with the
Blaze and he's up there interviewing
everybody boom you know he goes after
Isa so you know now that you know
everything that you know uh did you take
the covet vaccine and how do you feel
about the decision right and he says did
you take any of the vaccine no Mike
Pence hey so you know now that you're
this you know what do you think about
that well I'm glad you're paying
attention that I'm running yes but how
about this right yeah one by one by one
by one that is very scary it's not a
duplicatable skill set for a guy like
him to do Tucker but the key is is this
guy gonna get the itch because at the
Turning Point USA event with Charlie
Kirk
afterwards I'm asking everybody and I
want to know who stole the show you know
like at UFC fights the guy get a 50
bonus you're gonna give that's maybe
it's not the main card but it's someone
that steals a show okay
it was
60 40. Trump 60 40 Tucker yeah so it's
like Tucker's coming in to you know but
but the part that he's not doing right
now is which I think is going to work in
his favor he's not going in there saying
I'm not running this time around you
know he comes out and says in 2028
and imagine if a let's just say Trump
wins and he runs 2028 and Trump's
endorsing him I mean he could be in
office for eight years